hey I'm Ross Tran from the YouTube
channel rough gel you can see my art at
Roscoe's hi my name is Anthony Jones and
you can follow me at robot pencil and
today we're gonna be drawing characters
from memory I mean I grew up with
Nintendo's like my first like video game
series you know I think my first game
that I played probably Ocarina of Time
like that's my dad playing at first and
then I started to play it yeah Nintendo
was like my first exposure to video
games yeah I feel like not everybody
just jumps online I'm excited are you
excited
I love Nintendo I'm a Nintendo fan girl
like I grew up on Nintendo games I still
play Nintendo games you don't have a
Nintendo switch that's totally fine I
respect your opinion
well because everyone can afford I was
about to go real south and real soon but
I 1000 games are great and if you have
the excess funds to purchase one I
highly recommend it I don't have a
switch you're different
I hate you already be sure to stick
around to the end of the video to find
out how you can enter for a chance to
win this Wacom Intuos s tablet courtesy
of our friends at welcome Kevin made me
sign it everyone's gonna sign it but
Kevin music I never make you do anything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you just gonna do voices this entire
episode yeah it's a B Mario is that he
said my friend Yoshi
oh that's Pikachu that's a really good
withdraw Jackie oh that's awesome dude
it's right up your alley
and it's a girl I draw robots we both
have something in that I know the
general colors we got like red and gold
over there
right a helmet is it a green element
really I'm pretty sure because I'm drawn
Sam hold on hold on listen I'm Jon Sam
as two times in the past year so I would
remember the green hiya we're talking
about og
oh my god
okay so evil Mario I have a friend named
Jackie who loves Yoshi
it's not me I promise it's not like a
joke Jackie files if you're out there
this one's for you did you ever play any
of the
like WarioWare games and I love
WarioWare yeah it's so much fun
no Aria is a really good character him
in waluigi mm-hmm I love them but yeah I
don't think I've ever drawn them before
so Yoshi is a dinosaur he comes from
like a dinosaur egg he comes from
Yoshi's Island dinosaur island Jurassic
Park
welcome to Yoshi's Island Samus is one
of my favorite characters no really I
think it's because she was like one of
the very first like female characters
like that twist at the end and this one
character that's going through this
crazy dungeon fighting all these aliens
and it comes to find out it's a female
protagonist which is cool my Yoshi is
starting to look like a horse like my
horse yeah how did you do that because
like he's he has to have like a dip in
his back for Mario to sit on right he
doesn't have to look like a horse yeah
so this is a technique that I do to look
at the drawing from another fresh
perspective I do this a lot in my
professional work it's just to kind of
see all mistakes that I know I'm we
don't see it's like looking into a
mirror or reflecting herself and seeing
like a different kind of perception so
I'm changing my perception a lot when I
flipped my canvas to get a fresh take on
what I'm doing
Steph what's your favorite Nintendo game
that's a big question
I love the Zelda series overall and I
think I always kind of go back and forth
between what my favorites are but it
almost always lands on Wind Waker I
think it's like aesthetically a really
gorgeous game it's beautiful yeah what
is your favorite I love you know I'm
really good at doing toad okay give me
some of your toad right give me your
best Mario
how do you think you're doing so far
definitely not on model I feel like it's
essence of Wario more than it is Wario
whispers of whoa yeah this isn't too far
from what I actually do like I worked on
a cinematic called
aura or Starcraft yeah legacy of the
void cinematic a lot of the characters
there were designed by me it is
essentially like this like like here's a
character design of our game but we just
want to like level it up a little bit
yeah you know or just like modernize it
and that's kind of like what I'm trying
to do with this Samus character I'm
trying to make it feel like oh yeah if I
could that's what I do I wouldn't make
this Yoshi cube but he looks dumb and I
don't know how to fix it oh I have no
idea how to fix mine I'm gonna be fit
I'm gonna be fit on purpose
you're gonna what I'm gonna be fit on
purpose what does be fit me and Jackie
cuz I have a definition of what be fit
means you don't know what be fit me I
mean means you made a mistake right also
when I was growing up though be fit
meant to fart let's be fit with Kevin's
WG like I like Ross a lot because his
channel is very popular in his his whole
energy is just like art is fun artists
commit we can do we're living and I
think that's really powerful and that's
why I like this too is I can I know
there's gonna be some kid out there
watching this draw watching all the
other people draw and you're like wait
what I can do this make it live in AI
feel the bromance thank you thank you
for the love he doesn't have ears he's a
dinosaur oh wait he doesn't have ears I
don't think so I gave him ears I don't
think he has yours bro I want to give
him ears
no come on I'm sticking with the ears
what kind of ears did you even give it
look man I guess they're kind of
cat-like Oh Jackie I just Kevin I'm
beefing it's tough saying they think it
smells so bad so bad guys I'm starting
to question this green helmet stuff now
hold on I figure it out it's it's this
part oh yeah I can see yeah oh no that's
yeah I know no just a little bit of
tough to hit I don't know I think his
hat covers most of it
well he has bangs now here's a cell
right I think he is a shell oh no really
what is Mario sit on the shell part I
don't think he why are you drawing a
horse
I think I'm drawing a horse Jackie I
think you're thinking of a great work I
think I'm a great force
have you read the fan theories that like
all the Mario games are an elaborate
stage play no yeah there's just kind of
this theory that all the games that you
play are are just performances by all
the characters and so that's why
sometimes they're all playing and being
friends and sometimes they're all
archenemies well that's cute and
wholesome yeah what time is it color
done it's color dodge time let's do it
okay here we go man I'm like coloring
everywhere he already got so sweet it
tastes so good
the color dad you're having the time
your life with her I'm James Blair now
this is way better than the other one I
think Steph how do you think you did I
feel like he's a little too Mario like I
wasn't able to pull him into the Wario
realm how did your worried I turn out I
turned out better than I thought he was
going to um yeah I think he could be
grosser how well did you think he did I
think I did great
yeah yeah I I don't think that I got the
details right I'm almost certain I'm at
how about yourself if someone were to
pass by this o is just a version of
samus yes for sure yeah how do you think
he did not correct me me there's not
I don't it's not correct we beefed it we
beefed it it is so smelly in here there
is so much ranked air yeah I'm basically
breathing another person's bowels I
think we should just switch
we got a Nintendo switch yeah you made
your kit you're Sam as a super around
oh this is so much better no it is it oh
you got him though you like got his his
being thank you I forgot is the ears are
pointed dude you got like that the nose
and the moustache oh so we like
remembered the outfit pretty somewhere
we did yeah pocket which I hope he has
watch she's not gonna have it you're
definitely a lot closer than me why did
you it felt right when I was working on
the sketch and you're right now that
it's done
we're all geniuses in hindsight Jackie I
don't understand
also you gave him cowboy boots so Wow
does it look as wrong as giving Yoshi
completely new rims
maybe Yoshi has lots of different shoes
well he doesn't have cowboy boots I know
that
just give us yeah oh my god with gold
shoulders it's it's the green Canon the
candy yeah the Canon is a different
color this I helped you with that green
helmet no this copy for copy you cheated
there's so much more I think I could
have done I still had a lot of fun I
didn't I think I'm inspired by looking
at this I'm like oh man I'm inspired by
my friend that's something here's why I
gave him ears because his eyes going up
like that made me think ears wrong yeah
it got switched in my brain I will say
Kevin body's pretty good really I think
my body is like the thing that makes him
look like a horse those shoes why did we
remember like brown shoes we got pretty
close to it we got something yeah we're
Wario Jason
bring out the Smash Brothers version I'm
sure there's pockets you know what
Nintendo I love your games and I love
you and I'll keep playing your games
until I die even after the horrible
experience that we just went through I
will still pre-order all your games send
me a switch Thank You eNOS will you
switch alright giveaway time so if you
want to enter for a chance to win this
walk them into us tablet all you have to
do is go to BuzzFeed comics on Instagram
that's at comics on Instagram look for
this post and follow the instructions in
the
description best of luck to you best of
luck to you that's creepy no it's lovely
and I get lovelier every day
[Music]